all right folks maniacs and cool people
who came on the internet to see me just
because you don't know who I am we're
talking with a couple of nerd icon
legends and I can call them that because
we're all nerds here and so it's okay
it's a compliment and we're talking with
Nathan Fillion and Clark Gregg on Joss
Whedon's new epic much ado about nothing
how did this happen
Clark go and do that well I was told
though I wasn't included that there were
some Shakespeare brunches I thought you
were there I can remember you being
there I was waiting tables yeah I wish I
served you a wonderful you were
excellent blueberry muffin yeah but I
know I wasn't there so talk about that
Shakespeare brunches at Josh's house an
email would go out saying every who can
make it will respond from that he would
cast a Shakespeare play hmm this is the
play this is the book we're using these
two characters are not one character
this one was a girl and and we we do a
Shakespeare brunch in his backyard and
he was saying we should film one of
these one day which I honestly thought
meant filming us reading it video take
the brunch yeah but that not a real plan
not his plan that's really
because one of my questions was actually
I was gonna say is are these like
barbecues in his backyard that he comes
up with this idea and apparently it did
exactly and when we actually started
filming I thought it was gonna be far
more casual and it was actually a it's a
production it was a really yeah trucks
and everything yeah lights when you guys
were doing the brunches was this one of
the better readings well I didn't we
didn't read this one we did Twelfth
Night didn't we just want another one
not the one I didn't attend I did two of
them huh and this was something like 12
days like no time whatsoever
hold it which is funny because my
friends and I we love to make short
films when I was a kid and it took two
weeks to film four minutes this is a
hundred minute movie in 12 days I'll
film the black and white yes and you too
this is the first time that you two have
been in movie together finally yes yeah
now you're inducted into the Joss Whedon
family as let's call because now you're
gonna be more stuff of his family so
I've actually only been working for him
since the Avengers for the most part
after the Avengers I had dinner at his
house with a bunch of people where he
was basically celebrating the end of
photography and was about to start
editing and he said oh I'm not gonna go
on vacation I'm gonna shoot this film in
my house much
nothing and next thing you know I was
there trying to learn the lines and I
was in it and those seeing all these
people in shows and films that I'd loved
right and I thought I hope they're nice
to me and they will play very much work
and and now I know I'm doing agents of
shields yes jaws and his brother Jed and
Jed's wife Moe and and that's coming out
this fall which is funny because Coulson
let Coulson lives which is very
important because joss whedon I wouldn't
say who's notorious but he does kill off
people he kills people
he kills folks up and he brought you
back somehow that's a first
I think I think the Marvel Universe is a
little bit more accessible to the
concept of people not being a hundred
percent dead and I also was lucky to
have some people who started writing
Coulson lives all over the globe yeah
that's the hash tag of the entire show
I've seen this shirts I'm gonna get it
on someone's shirt immortalized they got
the the busts of the the red white and
blue yeah you have one don't worry um
Joss Whedon says always to me I was like
it always looks like it's work but it's
in disguise it's really play in disguise
of work is that how it is or is it wife
no he's a director like any other
director and best job ever yeah yeah
yeah working for Joss it's something I
three
I rarely had as much fun or been as
scared as I was doing much to do about
nothing just busy there was so little
time and it was Shakespeare Yeah right
is it is it Shakespeare speak as much as
V and that looks binding is that all
those yeah no it's not rewritten it is
Shakespeare hmm cut down but it's not
like when you're in high school and the
kid next to you is made to read it out
loud and he's reading it in monotone and
he stops at the end of the line because
that's when the line that's not how
shakespeare's i am if you tell all the
ideas it's like conversation that's
right it done well done correctly with
the power of Clarke and it it it's just
conversation it makes sense don't say
like it's Shakespeare when I was we I
think a Joss Whedon Shakespeare
collaboration is long overdue
when I was a kid I was the kid while the
kid was reading that I was sleeping I
was napping yeah in the back when I was
practicing my autograph right yeah I was
practicing your autograph - that's weird
um yeah no one's gonna be sleeping doing
this this is as Josh said this is the
sexiest thing he's ever done he's right
there's a lot of kind of this is a
summer party with intrigue and sex and
drinking ginger which is yeah but you're
cool because Shakespeare has been done
in modern time before but it it was we
all thought we dropped acid and watched
Romeo and Juliet that's the way that
happened right yeah but this is very
this is black and white it's very real
it's fun is a dark comedy no I would say
it's a romantic comedy with a subplot
that has a lot of drama in it yeah yeah
there's some very real danger in this
movie there are some people who get very
upset but for right now a good reason
yeah
forget one of these good reason good
reason is imagine a man's daughter
accused of being a want to move on at
the altar of her wedding yet she's
called out for having spent the night
before her wedding with another man yeah
remains to be seen whether my daughter
actually did that or if she's being set
up by some nefarious characters and in
fact my whole world would come to an end
if there wasn't one man one sheriff in
that town Nathan Fillion but I wouldn't
have slept through that if they pitched
that like that in high school right see
for me it was just boring Ron yes but
now Clark him said were you in the pitch
room for this I was you were okay that's
why I'm Lisa Elizabethan England get out
too tired from playing in no I feel you
those are those flights to LA men when
you use your arms they will exhaust you
yes joss whedon movies usually they have
comedy in them and this is a romantic
comedy with very dark tones is is just
Wheaton's comedy has ever meant to be a
comedy or is it like it's written and
then you're doing it you're like well
that would be kind of funny if that
happens it's an improv very little of
what Josh Wheatley does mmm it's by
accident mm-hmm there's there's there's
I'd say less than 1% of
what he puts on the screen happened
without his tedious planning the evil
mastermind he is yeah nothing is left to
chance
right certainly certainly things come to
life when he puts the people together
there's he does he has a way of letting
things live and breathe and catching the
right people and and putting things in
their capable hands it's it's really
amazing to watch but ya know I don't
think a lot happens that's my opinion my
humble opinion
I am H oh I don't really say the words
as written i-i've you the script kind of
as a blueprint I think you know that he
creates a world where it feels very
improv is a tour II and yet you never
really feel the impulse to leave the
script because it works and the script
itself feels very spur-of-the-moment hmm
what's a lot of scripts don't the only
way you can kind of make them feel alive
is to tweak them a little bit as you go
but you can't don't do that bad actors
do not get teachers and hashtags about
them that's true um he's jasmine is he's
probably he is one of if not the busiest
guy in Hollywood right now he's mr.
Marvel Avengers straight off that much
ado about nothing Avengers to producing
agents of shield is he a vampire or is
he a Kryptonian one of the dude he's not
a big sleeper yeah me we're at the
upfronts
in New York from crushingly long day of
press and announcing the shield shows
going forward and I mean I left I left
the party at 3:00 and Joss was still
dancing so yeah I've seen him dance til
morning
with his son up so I know he's not
vampire and he was a collection of
Kryptonite so we can't beat Tony yeah
he's a new thing altogether
he's something else he's what he is
abalone and vampire returnee and vampire
sent from the future back through time
by a robot to make movies better in this
day and age come with Joss if you want
to live
come with him if you were to live you
know what I love about Colson is that
it's because he's an agent but other
agents you're like okay when they go
away I don't know what they do they get
they puff away and smoke and go back to
the big metal lab but you've like
Coulson's like and that go home and then
you might not have food there maybe he
needs to go to Costco he deals with
everything I deal with but he's like a
super agent there's not a God in the
chest with a big room BFG 9000 god yes
and that's very cool
it's funny you know that I come when
they give me Carson's wallet every day
in the props right there's a Costco card
right is there a Costco card absolutely
it's mostly been used to buy ammunition
that's right oh but are there any scenes
with you guys in them yes there are my
first game my first thing was just was
with Clark and Brett we were in the
front yard of Josh's house it was my
first experience being there I watched
Clark he was it was running lines I she
said she's a friend of mine an actress
but also spectacularly talented at
helping people learn lines quickly
believe it or not watch him run his
lines like a machine right and I'm and
I'm people doing something over there
he's just four steps away doing his
stuff and oh my god he's got a lot to
say doesn't he and then turn around and
face camp and then start doing the same
lines but now with wait the same lines
but going know what now you have agents
of shields coming out is on ABC right
yes this fall yes so they tell me is it
so yeah who knows so far so good
I don't know it might be on the internet
by then but uh you are you're in the
show or do you carry the show I think
that's that's the theory of those
involved that Agent Coulson is kind of
driving the ship but I'm surrounded by a
spectacular ensemble of young shield
agents the Magnificent ming-na wen who
who plays agent Melinda may who's a very
notorious badass within shield right see
here's the thing about Clark he never
plays intimidating so he never believes
that he's actually intimidating he's
very intimidating you are I could see
that the Devils in the eyes kind of
right there that look you just yet
and then I have it's in the car don't
make me take it out I've done see you're
you're a wolf in sheep's clothing Clark
no other person could have just we can
kill them get resurrected carry a show
to come out this fall that will probably
get signed on again because people like
me will watch it Clark you're breaking
ground I'm a ground break for my friends
I don't know what to say that I hope
that's true I'm excited to shoot the
show we've only shot one went pretty
well I'm excited to see where it goes
now have you shot just the pilot episode
or I'd be shown a string of episodes we
shot the pilot episode and they picked
that up in about six seven weeks we
start shooting more of them and we will
have just enough more of them in the can
that they will will be theoretically
ahead of when they show them on TV oh
you got one more minute to speed it up
all right Nathan Fillion thank you for
talking with me that was easy yeah I try
to make it easy on people I try to make
these young people with better hair than
me Clark Gregg thank you guys talking
with me it's been a pleasure you guys
are masters catch them both you can
catch Nathan Fillion on CASL also on NBC
right hey DC I'll spin it on ABC and you
can click catch Clark grants why I
brought two cameras man I knew I was
like he's gonna be clip you can catch
Clark Gregg on agents of shields coming
out this fall on ABC and can catch them
both and Joss Whedon's new epic much ado
about nothing
Coulson lives
[Music]